welcome back to pj chain design today i
would like to talk about how to create
this
flower petal looking uh seat for
the pearl to set are you ready let's get
started
i'm going to start it at the front view
we're going to set it up for the ring
size for whatever that fitting into your
ring size
i highly recommend that make it into the
true size you want to have then i'm
going to
draw a straight line starting from
zero and with the two arm and for
whatever
the degree you want the ring to uh to
open
then the command i'm going to use
is curve front to view and we're going
to pick up
this one and this one that allows us to
have
this over here and the reason i'm doing
that is because
if i just turning around this one
for example as you can see the
ring will become oval right here and
this is really important
if it turning over your ring size is
going to be
smaller so this is really important here
we want to actually keep the ring size
correctly
so let me turn this into the red colors
is easier for you to see okay now we
want to creating the profile i'm going
to
using the conic corners for the
rectangle
i'm gonna snapping into the cauldron and
holding my
shift coming back for whatever size you
want your ring to be
and simply just moving this from the
midpoint
to the quadrant so that will be right
there and
keep in mind that and this is really
important too
this line over here need to be straight
if you have this guy
tilted as you can see it's cutting into
inside of the ring
and the size won't be correctly so make
sure that it's facing nose and south
second thing i wanted to do is create a
profile on the other side
for a better control so i'm simply just
going to use a rotate tool
and pick up my object snapping to the
zero and i'm just gonna rotate it 180
degree over there so to create a surface
we are going to
use the sweep one rail this is the rail
cross section
here and here make sure they are aligned
and i usually like to align to inside of
a ring shank that has a last
problem uh when you need to do anything
after that
and make sure you close the sweep so
then you will get your ring in the right
side we're simply going to
have this one and then to mirror to the
other side
like this so then we will have the
bottom ring and make sure the size is
correctly
now that's working on the setting for
the pearl you can
bring in any size of a pro that you like
i simply just want something
super big for this giant pearl
maybe that's too big to reach
okay so i think that's a decent size i'm
going to have a pearl going up a little
bit
and that will be the space for my
setting to sit
in there and let's turn off the ring so
it's we have a
clean design there let me lock in this
one so let's do our design
first so i'm gonna use the arc tool and
i'm going to snapping into the zero
and coming over here holding my shift
get it really close
but not past the size of my pearl
and i want to go something like this
okay with this
one simply just want to mirror to the
other side
and go ahead to join them if they are
too fat
you can always one de-scale it down to
be the right size that you want
the second thing is i'm going to making
a copy by snapping into
the end point and coming over here for
minus 45 degree and let me turn this off
it's
easier for you to see so for this one
i'm going to make them smaller
or you can make them thinner if you want
to in this case
i'm going to 3d scale and gonna snapping
into
the end point over here and make them a
little bit smaller
double make sure this is the pattern
that you want i wanted to
cut it out the middle so uh roughly
about
0.6 or 0.7 millimeter
i want to use the offset the curve
to have this cut it out okay so i'm
going to bring back the pearl
making a copy first so i'm going to ctrl
c
control v which is copy and paste
and hiding one of it all right so
we are going to dealing with this curve
first and we are simply just going to
trim it
the one in the middle okay
and now you can see this is the surface
that we have
and we can delete the one on the top i
simply want to make them
into the thickness so let's go ahead to
use the offset surface
and you want to offset outside otherwise
gonna hit the pearl that you have
i'm going to offset for .7 millimeter
and then make sure solid equal yes then
we'll have
this shape here
the second one we're going to do the
same thing again let's turn on the pro
that we have
again making a copy hiding one of this
and gonna pick up this curve
and using the trim command to trim this
one
and also trim the one in the middle to
give it more dimension
this one i wanted to offset the surface
a little bit shallower so maybe 0.55
and hit enter so you can see they are
different depth there let's make them a
little bit nicer by giving a fitted
edges
so let's do something 0.15 millimeter
and we want to go with this one and this
one
if that look good to you you want to go
ahead to
make all the fillet edges the same and
we only need to do
outside we don't need to do inside all
right so then we'll have this fill
edges double make sure that they are
right
they are closed solid polished surface
okay to make them into the seat
we basically go into polar array
and we gonna set it up the center as
zero
and i wanted to have four four of them
for 360 degree
and that's how we get this seat now
let's go ahead to turn on the pro
i'm going to change to other colors and
also
turn it back to our ring i wanted my
ring to set it a little bit lower here
so they will have a good contact
over there most of the time let me turn
this off and most of the time the pro
will have a post there
so we simply it's going to put the 20
gauge wire over here
and setting up a radius for 0.4
millimeter and
how long do you need it since we are
going to cast this
it's better to have enough than not
enough and we can always trim it off but
the proper length will be half size of
the pearl
i just want to make them a little bit
longer that way
i will ensure the casting will come out
the rest of it will be the b
setting if you like to learn more about
a stone setting also check out my course
thank you for watching let me know what
you think about this tutorial at the
comment below
and i will see you next
[Music]
you